my name is Francesco I'm former game
developer I've been in the trenches for
few years about 15 and as bill mentioned
tools are important are as important as
at least for me a game is as good as the
tools you used to make it as I said
spent so many nights waiting for tools
to finish something or waiting for a
profiler to capture a frame that if I
don't get a a good tool if working on
the game becomes unbearable and the less
time you spend profiling the bugging
creating assets it's the more time you
can spend at the pub if you are from
England I work there or you can spend
polishing the game it's probably a
better use at the time we get this
that's why we're working a lot on tools
now in Google a lot of my time is
literally spent pacing in the office
back and forth just we need good tools
we need good tools we need good tools
people are getting tired of this but one
of the outcomes is that we now have we
now have a native profiler in Android
studio a native C++ profiler
it's a profiler as every profiler that
that you know but now it exists in
Android studio we also have system trace
which lets you have a more holistic view
of the entire system running you can see
the processes we're gonna see an example
of this and now just on trace exists but
good luck using it from the command line
now we have it in under studio
integrated with a great UI and my
favorite one is we have a graphics API
debugger not Google API debugger
it's about graphics not about Google but
it's literally you will see you can see
every single draw call in OpenGL in
Vulcan and you can replay it it's it's
also minutes my favorite tool
now as I mentioned we can sample native
C++ threads the only limitation has
works on API 2608 it's not a big deal
and that's how it works now I was
writing some code and I left some
debugging log in an inner loop raise
your hand if you have never left the
bugging code in your inner loop I don't
believe you well that means that when I
click on the button things got a little
bit slow come to the bugger you can see
there something is weird in Java calm
piglet my application piglet is my kid
and their name things after him and you
can see how I press the button and CPUs
backed up right there and here as you
would expect a lot of time is spent in
to do something cool which was near loop
so it's a profiler is every other
profiler that that you know but now it
exists and you can do this kind of stuff
which saves time instead of trying to
guess back to system trace system trace
is a tool that is events based so it's
not a dozen sample as an active profiler
it's based on events that are fired from
from the system it records all these
events and then it shows that all these
events in a common timeline where you
can see both the application and the
system process yes and this is very
interesting because you can see what
things are running on the system in
which core how they are interacting in a
in annalistic timeline and it lets you
the bug flow frames very very easily
because it highlights them if a frame is
running it is taking more 33
milliseconds to run well the UI will
show you in this video I there's a lot
of information part here
you can see the very CPU cores all the
threads you can reorder threads just to
have friends that are common together
it's very useful you can see that this
threat to is visually using a lot of CPU
the the bright areas and you can see
there a very interesting formation most
of the CPU is happening mostly CPU time
is spent on the CPU on the core 3 the
other course are relatively light how I
use the information where it depends on
what you're trying to do but for example
this would tell me
ok wait a second I might get a little
better framerate if I take this work and
I spread across multiple threads but now
you don't have to guess these will tell
you let's look at this render thread
again here it's using quite a lot of CPU
and you can see other icing signals
tasks that are running on in parallel
this is telling you another interesting
formation you do have a render thread
that you separate from the main thread
good job something that generally you
want to do
now let's look at this trace you can see
that playing bitmaps there's this
particular friend is using a lot of CPU
fine that's alright but you can also see
that it's jumping from one chord to the
other it's being scheduled on different
cores
now let's imagine you're already hitting
your framerate so you're good for the
framerate this information could be used
to say okay let's try to to set affinity
for this thread to as low core and let's
see if we can save some battery or let's
put it on a fast cord let's see if we
can save some battery there this way
because the work is finished earlier so
everything can go to sleep quicker
instead of just jumping around but the
takeaway that I want from this is you
can see it visually instead of trying to
guess which is what we were doing it for
the red bar means this is a slow frame
and this tells you that this frame is
taking 200 milliseconds with like more
than 33 and something weird is happening
inflate this might suggest that some
some assets are being taken unpacked
during the during this frame might be
weird something going on there but again
you see it visually as I mentioned this
is this system records events you can
insert your events as well and record
that you can for example let's imagine
that you have a shadow pass you want to
look at a shadow pass in which thread is
running and and where is happening
compared to the rest of the system well
you can insert custom events and there I
give you a nice scope trace you stick it
at the beginning of a function and there
you are
this function is recorded
in the future we're gonna show in the
main UI also the V sinks which is very
interesting to see if we are hitting the
view sync with your friends visually I'm
gonna support both 30 and 60 frames per
second or if you're making a racing game
you don't want to run 30 limitations the
limitation on the eye on API to API 23
before it only runs to a single process
for now but there will be lifted you can
export traces but you can import traces
yet it's gonna be fixed it's working
progress my third one
kept it it's correctly graphics debugger
da and gap it is for the ones who the
lucky ones we use pics it's the
beginning of pics get in there
it lets you trace capture trace inspect
the trades visually and replay the trace
on the same device there's limitation it
works both on Vulcan and OpenGL it works
on Android and Mac and Windows and
that's how it looks
that's awesome that's me being very
happy about it you can see every single
joke all what is rendering the frame
buffer lets you inspect shaders lets you
change the shader on-the-fly and
replayed on device very good if you're
an artist who likes using it tap it as I
mentioned works in OpenGL and walking
there are some limitations there for
example I remember correctly OpenGL
doesn't let you capture mid mid for me
Tron Vulcan does there are limitations
but again these two is working progress
and thank it exists and they're
improving in that all these limitations
will be lifted eventually
it's all available system trace is
available now you can unload it in three
point two in the Connery there's a link
to the Connery gap it has been released
it's one point zero please give us
feedback and now everyone says please
give us feedback we actually do act on
the first place if you feel like if you
tell me these things doesn't work on gap
it I literally would walk to that to the
team to the lead of the team and I start
banging on the desk until they got a fix
and it did it so it works really give
any question feel free no write me if
you can start and stop the trace
programmatically just because we have a
big game sometimes we want to just look
at a particular area of the game no
write me my email and I will file a bug
and I will can you tell me the use case
for it uh yeah a lot of times these
graphics systems they run out of memory
before you're even into your you want to
look at what yeah it's the point what
kind of tracer he's trying to start and
stop we're trying to start record a CPU
tracer memory
yes these captured multiple frames by
the way but it can be used to capture
personally I'm a gigantic fan of
capturing only one frame not everyone
agrees with me on this I do agree with
myself on this one
hi I actually lead GAAP it currently for
Vulcan you can do mid execution capture
so there isn't an API in the game or
there isn't an API that you can use to
programmatically start it but there's a
button that you can start an arbitrary
point there's a certain amount of
shadowing that we have to do there is a
overhead but it's not as much as an
entire driver copy for Julius we're
working on it if you want a API to
trigger it it will be very easy to add